i'm scared to listen to the future stuff
yeah no i don't know i don't want it
y'all can do it yeah some of you guys no
i don't want anybody
either they're my i see i see you on a
bike
next year having a heart attack yeah
your future is easy to predict
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
whose birthday is it is that every time
he wears a cowboy hat
birthday is it whose birthday is it i
see that one
day that's like i guess theo's gonna do
it you know
oh there you go huh wow i got real urban
up in here yeah
urban cowboy dude it got bro it just
went from
zero to freaking north fresno
[Laughter]
it just went from straight up
dude how are you you are obviously from
stockton
obviously right now huh i ain't never
been to stockton dude
lies in that hat this is like that hat
on uh harry potter that tells the truth
[Laughter]
you look like billy ray cyrus's tour
manager
what does he sing achy breaky heart yeah
yeah yeah
he's got another one he also produced
miley cyrus son
he what he also produced miley cyrus
which seems exaggerated
for his daughter yeah which seems pretty
smart his thick
nut sweat oh that's what you're saying
yes i thought you were producer music
dude it's awkward over on this side dude
it is yeah
how do you think i feel my whole life
brandon you know
now you know how other people feel yeah
what are you like
wait until you sit a mile in someone
else's chair
you gotta live a little man it's whose
birthday whose birthday
birthday is his birthday dude why don't
we have a new birthday song huh
yeah chabelle don't let darris rutgers
see you now oh
hey come on let's team we have to do
backflips for every [ __ ] show
i know gosh i'm sick of doing those
everywhere in salt lake city
everywhere we go they're like yeah we
heard you can do a back flip
oh i always ask and then the owner keith
of the of wise guy's like man
during during corona to build the stage
myself so it's a little sketchy so be
careful whatever you're doing no way
because your bell is like i don't know
that stage seems sketchy he's like yeah
there's certain parts man
oh yeah yeah we all performing outdoors
in salt lake
no indoor wise guys oh nice yeah wise
guys
oh yeah they haven't set up i've been
over there oh there's a picture of you
guys right there look at
jay schabb on that right that big that
big old
bumble bee and he go i tell him i go
you're looking like
fat not thick and he goes ah it's the
shirt
no it's not homeboy he looks like one of
them fat bumblebees huh you know there's
like bees and there's that always that
fat thick beef that's what he's like
bumblebee he looks like kind of that
like uh like a item in the uh frozen
area that's like kind of stretching the
uh cellophane a little bit in the meat
in the frozen meat area
dang he is getting really thick huh yeah
it's the shirt
okay i don't know i know i know i don't
know man i've seen shirts that
make people just look exactly like they
are
he looks like a gravy bee he's just
thick yeah he looks like they get that b
they got stuck somewhere yeah even gravy
he looks like that biscuits and gravy he
looks like a spelling bee but all the
words he can't get them out
it's just stuck in them and most of the
words are frosting
wow man and how was he on those scooters
with that weight it seems like
yeah and what is he is he is he putting
on he's a satchel as well
is he putting on chub or muscle there i
think he's but a both he says he's
balking but
but what does that mean he's summer and
so
no one bulks in the summer that makes
sense you're right
no then when i tell my do you put on
some weight you go i still got abs like
i don't believe that
i just don't believe that anymore maybe
he's right right in this summer off and
just gearing up for next year since
we lost of quarantine it's a thick boy
summer man yeah it's a fake boy's summer
i took these boys on bikes yeah it looks
like you guys got scooters out there you
guys did everything huh
we would we would go and it's lit out in
salt lake city like the clubs open the
bars open we go
go find everyone see us not sheila we
gay
yeah we gay we get it y'all okay these
guys want to take our pictures i went we
gay
wait what what they don't they don't
like that [ __ ] out there
you gotta be progressive man that's what
i like to see dude malik was like hey do
you
quit saying that [ __ ] man it's like just
kept doing it dude what i like to see is
really aggressive gays violent gays you
gotta see
you know there's a there's a lot of the
old school gay style
you know i'm going to be over here i'm
going to do art you know
yeah we weren't doing that my paint my
dad you know
you know i came out the closet my dad
took my truck away for two weeks you
know
you see a lot of that kind of stuff but
i'm ready for the new age gays the tiger
king
yeah tiger king tim dillon
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying dude jesse
smollett attack gays
yeah yeah attack gays mike piazza yeah
that's where we're coming from catch a
ball
here they are there's the oh that's a
ball dude
pocket your bat you know what i'm saying
okay mike joss is the only
player that would dress up dress up in a
batboy uniform and sneak out and get the
bad every time
this is the biggest bad boy you've ever
seen yeah little sugar is taking
you running back to that dugout you're
supposed to be on second base right now
mike
whose birthday is it
uh and also dude there's a lot of new
progressive style people will you bring
up that um
the there's a black an african-american
uh right uh
wing kind of civil war veteran son if
you can
google that oh he's down with the
monuments
yeah who was that just a guy this is
what i like to see people going against
the grain
man you know because you've all
throughout time when you look at people
who've gone against the grain martin
luther king
you know he who else monsanto who's that
it's these people that like poisoned all
the grain in like the midwest like one
of those companies
he was like the real life clayton bixby
they said the blind white supremacist
from yeah this isn't it is that what
they call him and he's all for
he's all four uh confederate flags well
he's just uh what i like to see is a
different
it's just like everybody always puts
people in the same box
this guy is living in his own box man
it seems like a lonely box that's not it
it seems like a very
lonely confederate box right down there
one more
that's him alabama has some opposition
from about two dozen members and
supporters of the sons of confederate
veterans
regardless how the next person feels
my flag down if i got anything to do
with it ain't no monument gonna come
down
daniel simm says he was adopted as a
child my whole family is white
went to all white school grew up in all
white neighborhoods
my grandfather was white and he was the
main one that fought in this war
oh wait she told me everything god knows
you look like
how he'd feel if the statues and flag
were relocated
in my blood if they just come up here
and feel like they could just tear it
down
i don't see me still living if they do
that right there that monument ain't
hurting nobody
that moment ain't killing my soul it
ain't talking bad to nobody it ain't it
ain't even racist
but dunstan says she's confident her
group will be there's a lesbian right
there
you go back a little nick
is there lesbian confederates right
there
this bro right here she has a better
beard this power forward for antifa
right here
this small fort frantic yeah freaking
marshmallow anthony right here
carl post malone
[Laughter]
uh but i don't know i just think it's
brave to see somebody that's doing
something that's breaking
the mold like you don't see a guy like
this you know what i'm saying
well there's a lot but you but you don't
see them publicized you know like you
don't see these guys whoa
bro do not give us that hey right
actually
maybe give it to us you want to get it
over with everybody gonna get it
everybody
everybody everybody everybody can get it
i've been there man so there and there
we got another guy right here is this
antifa again this ain't
it oh no park city like
bro
they were so loud out there oh bro they
were
you know me stevie and jay where he saw
the darwin oh there's a deer everyone's
damn that's cool
and then wait wait oh [ __ ] it's a dare
it's all [ __ ] it's a damn god damn
dude it's now just called it it used to
be deer valley sounds valley resort
over there now what's interesting is i
we have to leave these three oh look at
this because they
they weren't used to biking so we win
left them behind me go on my own
and i was worried about chapelle you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] this side [ __ ] it's
inside
the hell going on chappelle going that
sauce
dude the white people were so
encouraging to us
how about justin ate [ __ ] nikes out
yeah we went up three times came down
we're eating
finally they came down once right and i
look at justin he has a huge bandage all
over
oh he was bleeding he ate it bad well
the whole idea is preposterous of
getting
fat people on the bikes like it's a just
outlandish that's the business you know
i understand the business model business
and i think it's positive
look i like what you guys are doing you
guys are the clayton biggs these are the
trails
now you guys were out you were just
saying how you like that i don't know
you're against it i
just think long term the the physical
right when it comes to the physical
brendan look what's going on with you
guys you you're strong enough but you're
getting guys out there with bad
pressure bad sugar you're right i was
worried about them hey i didn't fall
once you didn't fall
once i did i did [ __ ] yeah malik fell
justin fell i didn't i can do backflips
i'm not gonna fall off a mountain well
well you're right
well okay but so but i'm just saying
that you guys
can do better i think i'm saying guys
huh the big guys it's just how when does
somebody has a stroke
you know yeah you're right it was hot
out there too
was it i was worried about him and y'all
better bury him if they do
yep right there on the right there on
the mountain dog
right there on the trail oh thick boy
headstones what about that
an extra thick headstone yeah dude that
thing's thick
that thing's a foot deep man eight inch
wide headstone a foot deep bro it's not
a bad idea
dude that ski lift was scary though was
it that was our first time
that was all of our first time going on
there that thing went up pretty high and
plus
we didn't know there's a safety bar that
locks you in so we were just sitting
there like
without the safety bar yeah we were
holding on to the pole wow we was just
holding on
come on justin was in the middle he was
just holding on to me and malik
because we didn't know nobody told you
about the scene well there's people
coming the other way and they go
pull down the bar and we were like oh
okay and then we found them you're the
only
black guys on the mountain yeah we're
only two black guys up there yeah look
look at we don't have the bar we're just
holding it look how scary they are
nothing's scarier than seeing three
black dudes
in mass not behind bars okay
so obviously those people are saying hey
more
more bars put the bars down man yeah
yeah dude yeah
so but yeah man i can also understand
why you guys don't want to do it man
stevie was a little nervous about the
bars too man with this
earlier prison sentence stevie weavey
was still he was there tv blue
who is that stevie blue you never met
stevie blue eyes i'm not
comic wait is he married to eliza
schlesinger no
no no no no no that is not him
no oh that's great though you guys had a
good crew man it sounds like you guys
had a good time was it yeah it was fun
oh it was a lot fun yo man let me tell
you about
wellness bro i'm talking about
forehands.com need help with hair loss
not really real right
but i had also but sometimes if i don't
want to wear a hat then i want to take
care of my hair and i want to have hair
yeah you want to keep what you have how
about that how's that weaner working
you know it's moderate dude it's always
been moderately always be better though
am i right you get the sleepy
peepee yeah i got yeah i've never really
had that real excited fella you know i
remember when i was young my penis was
strong and then it really
i don't know if i was in a car accident
or what happened he got tired four hems
keep your hair
freaking help with your wiener problems
how about a covet 19 home test
hims is here to help you yeah bro yeah
man
i like that because then if you meet
somebody you say hey let me get this
tested let me get this checked out
whatever you want
my wiener check my covet check my hair
six six
percent of men start to lose their hair
by 35. oh you gotta keep what you have
man
thanks to science hair loss can be
optional do you want to be bald do it
dude live your life
but if you want here like theo and me
then use four
hems all right you want to take care of
your hair you want to take care of your
body your skin your peen everything
tighten up tighten and i'm telling you
right now today
hems is giving you their best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hems will give you a
full refund that's right our listeners
can get their first
visit absolutely free wow go to for
hims.com k-a-t-s
that's m s f-o-r-h-i-m-s-dot com
slash k a t s full refund of price paid
available for first 90 days supply
refund request must be made between 980
days after the product shipments
delivered prescription products required
online consultation and medical
professional determined if it's
purchased
the story restricting the supply chain
website for details and personal safety
information
okay okay man bro
my mom has been she won't stop calling
me she won't stop
energy so much energy she's green at her
oh dude it's crazy so yeah
it's just she's doing things she's doing
uh stuff around the house she got a
screwdriver the other day
i talked to psychic he said you need
more green in your life i said what
that's why i hook my mom up with
athletic greens developed from a complex
blend of 75 vitamins
and minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients it's that healthy
wealthy thing you put you're putting in
your body yeah man
athletic green is an easy all-in-one
solution to help your body meet its
nutritional needs all right all
in a drink with less than one gram of
sugar that tastes
delicious i thought the greens was
developed for athletes and just regular
folk man
when you try athletic greens through
this podcast they're going to give you
up to a year's supply of vitamin d3
k2 ain't talking about the mountain for
free pg praise god man and here's what
i'm going to tell you right now brennan
because you don't know a lot make sure
i'm going to shoot you straight with
this the uh
the deal we have for athletic greens
right now
that green powder you go to athletic
greens.com
k-a-t-s to get the special offer
and receive the free d3 k2 wellness
bundle with your first purchase
it's that it's that tank shirts that
drop for you just put it in
one year one year supply of vitamin d
you need it
get that d get that d that d in your
mouth
the daily all-in-one drink you'll be
hard-pressed to find
a more comprehensive nutritional bundle
anywhere
again that's athleticgreens.com k-a-t-s
green up and take care of your family
and yourself get that d
in your mouth brendan did you go cat
uh nope i went back home oh you went
home cap yeah i visited
my family again what's going on with
them in vietnam uh
no i did facetime or weird monk in
vietnam because my mom says that he
could predict the future
uh trump's gonna win uh he didn't say
anything about that he said that i need
to pray more
and that i had a lover in the past life
who's haunting me now and that's why i'm
single oh my god i can't see that
wow i could totally see that [ __ ] yeah
sorry i'm sorry you don't know that
right
shirtless slightly overweight and
speaking in tongues
yes oh well it sounds like he was missed
his bike trip
and so yeah sounds like he needs to get
on a bike
it all sounds like he was pitching his
shot against you
he has to see your feet no but i did
have to stand up and he had to see like
my full body in order to do that
yeah so i was like in a sweater he has a
metoo movement coming any day now it
sounds like
uh i think it'll take about five years
to get out there
in vietnam yeah and did um and what
who who recommended you do this kind of
thing is this like a regular occurrence
is this
my mom yes your mom talks to him all the
time uh not him all the time but anytime
somebody has to
do anything with like spiritual videos
people kind of yeah okay wow she's into
that
she loves it and so why was your mom
like oh let's call this guy this is why
you're singing because she cares about
her because he she cares about her
daughter brendan yeah
i think it makes her feel better that's
easy to me as long as he thinks i'll be
fine like i'll be fine
your mom's like that makes sense what's
his name carl i have no idea
carl's carl let's call him mon yeah
that's like uh
and he only spoke in carl yeah he spoke
in tongues
he was over how'd you understand no i
didn't understand there was a translator
there
holy [ __ ] so he had a translator that
yeah they do it to your sister too
yeah and apparently my sister is going
to live a very hard life
do you think he would zoom in at some
point maybe he might
can you but can we need a translator
right his translator i think travels
with him all the time so that's okay
he's bawling
he might be able to do something let's
make that happen no yeah that would be
great no is that oh we should get a
psychic on here
what whoa yeah yeah
now and that's also and i'm gonna go out
on a limb here and you can stop me if
you want chappelle but i will be out on
this limb if you need to go ahead
in the urban community and that's a
that is a racial generalization or the
dark chinese
some people refer to a black culture uh
sean like mystics and seances you guys
get more scared of that kind of stuff
did your
oh yeah that's just yeah freaky i mean
but you get yeah i think in new orleans
or whatever uh
dark they don't they do like the voodoo
yeah
isn't it like oh it's more popular down
there yeah when i was growing up there
was always you know mystics running
around you know
rain sticks we had a lady used to be a
rib reader she would read your ribs
i like that and a crap huh yeah like a
map like a bone map
oh wow um but i always had my black
friends would always get scared if
somebody came around with a ouija board
or somebody came around with a hit of
acid or something
so your family does it all the time cat
uh every now and then i actually okay
sorry i was talking to chappelle
sorry guys she was texting the guy okay
my bad
i'm sorry video of it i know there's
still a video of me oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm trying to air drop it to him
right now now back to
black people there's a lot of black
people doing it in
louisiana there's there were not a lot
of people there was more fear of that
kind of stuff yeah
they were scared of it got it what do
you think
yeah i'm scared of that [ __ ] yeah you
know there's a comic that that started
doing the readings you know thomas dale
yeah yeah yeah he does like those uh
readings everyone says it's like
we can get him in here oh we could
thomas dale does it he's a clairvoyant
any and he's gay yeah oh i love him yeah
he's a beast he's a beast he's fully gay
he's great he's a great comic he's he's
he's good at
comedy and reading people's minds and
[ __ ] well that's off that world
well we'll figure that out we'll be the
judge of that i'm telling you
the second part can be drug-induced
and no offense i hopefully it is you
know you don't want to meet a shaman
that's never freaking hit a rock you
know
i don't believe in him but i'd love to
have him in here but he's
so funny man it's really is he he's that
would be great that'd be great
he does it he does i think he does it
through zoom and stuff oh that's kind of
a bomber
but that's how he's doing it right here
his cat right here
that's my mom uh holding up the phone
and beautiful you guys look alike huh
uh yeah i look just actually i look more
like my dad but
that's what he looks like why is his
shirt up i don't know that's mine
oh that's money he's a little kid is he
14 yeah
i think he is like
17 or wow between the age of 17 to like
20.
oh apparently he he's had this ability
since he was a kid
you ever seen that kid on e the the the
kardashians and stuff yeah and he met
with robin thicke
i know like three months before yeah i
was like oh you have a heart problem rob
thinks like no i don't he's like i'm
telling you to get checked out
bam three months later he died heart
attack the kid did no
no kid called it how robin thicke was
200 years old dude
i couldn't tell you that three months
later though and they saw the
kardashians
right robin thicke robin thicke robin
fix the singer
yeah well no no no no his dad his dad
dude bob
allen allen dick i was like wait robin
thinks a lot
about alan thicke throbbing thick dude
that guy
couldn't handle robin you got a brand
doug
oh and this guy's young is that him
that's him that's a little yeah
this guy goes around town this guy seems
reliable
hey i trust him i trust him more than
cat's
14 year old that speaks in tongue with a
shirt off
bro really you're gonna trust a 14 year
old been some freaking drug twink that's
been out here
running around the hollywood hills
predicting that celebrities are gonna
die soon no [ __ ] it's been right though
a lot of times
they all die anything on e is complete
[ __ ] brendan
you know that yeah i did work with him i
did too
that was awesome yeah yeah i mean a lot
of it is just
it's not stuff i i would way more
believe cat who's from a
seance area vietnam dude
then somebody else like that little
white kid
the 14 year old kid only speaks with his
tits out
i mean is there anything more spiritual
than that though yeah his titties are
out
why does he have a shirt off cause he
doesn't need a shirt like this freaking
rich [ __ ]
yeah well he's rich because he's right
about it no he isn't he does live shows
i'm telling you go
go to the allen thick one it's mind
blowing there he is
he died yeah oh it's going to be
something that we really have to keep in
mind
i loved him now heart issues that happen
to men it's not uncommon but the thing
is is that
uh let me see what that is
he takes a piece of paper and he's like
you know what you're gonna have a heart
attack go get it checked out
that's why i tip my hat and leave the
show
[Laughter]
zoom calls everybody hey yeah i trust
that yeah i trust that comic
oh thomas yeah yeah let's get thomas in
here whoa
uh let's all i i love thomas is thomas a
good seancer
i don't know i don't think he's called
seanson i don't know
he's a medium yeah he's a media let's
let's see he there's a
he he offers it on his ig let's see what
he's saying here
yeah there we go yeah how could you not
trust that with the ponies you know
this is right now also usually he's
eating a bowl of bowl and now taking
appointments for september
uh august is fully booked so we are done
sold out
september is now open if you want to
have a reading with me a
medium or a clairvoyant session reach
out to me dm me now and book that slot
it's 60 bucks for 45 to 50 minutes or if
you just want to try a little starter
session see what it's like
it's 25 bucks for 20 minutes okay
creative during quarantine i will get in
touch with them
he's got i've had this has been so
amazing
for me and the people i've been reading
everybody's just been
completely loving it and it definitely
helps put you on a new path i will give
you the insight that you might need
uh leave a review down at the bottom at
the comments
should i send my money now i was like
well let's
do it what are the pricing again can you
go back to the pricing area it was 25
for 20 minutes 60 for
45 to an hour can we get how much for
four people
i'd like to get nick and chin in there
too so i want to
hear the pricing again i don't trust you
guys as recollection of the price
was it 49.99 or if you just want to try
a little chat to me dm me now
and book that slot it's 60 bucks for 45
to 50 minutes or if you just want to try
a little starter session
see what it's like it's 25 bucks for 20
minutes
okay you have some spirits you want to
hit up a minute
a dollar a minute i agree look i'm all
for it
i would love to get thomas in here and
discuss the future and the past at the
same time everyone everyone i've talked
to has loved it
oh yeah who's everybody like i've known
like five people to do it oh yeah like
that sounds vague
okay roger stewart ally mccalski did it
gabby lama did it my friend ashoka
thomas did it
um who else did it um some other some
more white people
you know a bunch of white people i don't
know if any yeah this is what we need to
do then we need to have a seance off we
need to have cat sky versus thomas dale
fighting yeah yes
that's a battle you know what i'm saying
let's have that lamp rub and see these
bad boys get at
dude i say we get that lava lamp in the
middle and have these boys go at it
oh yeah have them go out i'll tell you
what they looked up chin's dark
past ski you're pretty weird up in here
i know i'm hoping too scary
you're open in the past yeah but the
future i don't want to know
the past you can look into it as much as
you want god bless you for that well you
already know the problem
i'm the same way i'm with you you guys
don't know
and so i don't want to be too heavy here
but this is kind of heavy
so i had a friend that passed away last
year you know this
cat his mother was very much into this
stuff as well she's vietnamese she said
from
from childhood uh he would pass away
by the time he's 39 years old we were
with him on his birthday for his 39th
birthday and he passed away a
a day and a half afterwards did the mom
say this yeah and you believe so
i mean that's so freaking you know nail
like
do you think she's telling them so much
honor though the whole family knew it
that's why she kept praying during the
time
to honor your mother that much to die
when she wants you to i
think nothing there's nothing braver
really well there's nothing really yeah
i'm scared to listen to the future song
yeah no i don't need i don't want it
y'all yeah some of you guys no i don't
want anyone
yeah either they're my i see i see on a
bike
next year having a heart attack yeah
your future is easy to predict
that's why i'm going to save my money i
feel like yours is pretty easy to
predict too
yeah what being a dang western hero
brendan hey hey i salute to that one
thank you brother i appreciate that i
like tombstone up in this [ __ ]
like tombstone pizza yeah
dang i don't know if i'd do it either
now now i'm kind of nervous
chin dropped that dark face yeah man
that's scary i mean
your whole family believes in there
right or mom it's my whole family
so it's pretty pretty can you change the
like if he's like listen if you're going
at the rate you're going
no 400 pounds i'm ready to ride that
smoke bro i'm ready to know you ain't
scared and you do it on you'll do it on
the episode
yeah i'll get read out on the episode
oh we could do it for patreon but see
here's the thing about thomas thomas
doesn't
like um predict the future no he's not
going to tell your future it's like
i want my [ __ ] he just knows about
like uh recipes
oh what's he saying good spirits like
come to him
and say what i don't know i haven't done
it yet we have all these friends dude
you're vouching for him
yeah you have all these friends that are
winning the lottery all of a sudden
all these struggling comics they all
send them the next day chappelle
yeah all five of you yeah we gave him 60
bucks
you look like threat michael's bro
you look like you are definitely gonna
beat the [ __ ]
you you're gonna
that's that [ __ ] hat you'd wear on
rock love too yeah
that's not even his hair and why'd you
always have [ __ ] mascara on all the
[ __ ] time dude that's what
that's what they did back in the day
those bands yeah but this is in 2007
hold on you're gonna say an icon like
brett
michaels can't have a mascara
okay okay music one sean vh1 doesn't
make you an icon
but what is music flavor flavor had one
flavor of love that was dope
ah he's an icon yeah he's great
over threat michaels threat michaels
what was his fake most famous song
every rose has the word every rose has
its song
that was a crusher man that's the song
that every person learns to play on the
guitar first isn't it one hundred
percent
really i learned that too first that
wasn't foreign
no it's not look at it it says it
actually he didn't write that originally
i think that's uh chuck berry
something on skinny box skinny bob was
usually wrote
really let me hear skinny bop yeah you
don't understand
i respect that though oh
see that's how they did the music videos
back in the day those that mattered
those things
never heard the song in my life you did
you didn't even give it a chance
yeah i know right away never heard it
you know this give it a chance yeah wait
for the hook
i was raised to this dude my brother
used to beat me to this
what a song to beat someone too did your
brother have a poison tattoo too or no
no he he had poison in his heart
i mean look how beautiful that guy was
he's handsome dude
bro he's a he's an eight woman
[Laughter]
never heard the song in my life oh
really he's one of the only singers
you'll start listening to music and then
start
masturbating yourself with a wig on
trying to get on this bus dude he was
one of those big girls brother
he was the first that cartoon gym in the
misfits is based on him
jimin speaking of running out of gas
dude
[Laughter]
dude you're too old to be running out of
gas papa ran out twice last week
this week damn what is going on bro well
i mean it's last week but it's all it's
this week
yeah sure i'm still alive long sunday
um you ran out of gas huh yeah baby
how's that happen
you get the the take the alarm thing low
on gas
yeah they let you know one time brandon
just chillin bro uh
ran out of gas again you know it so
on the 405 here baby road
um there's two kind of people in this
world there's one when that gas light
comes on goes oh [ __ ] i gotta get to the
gas station
there's another one goes um i can push
this let's ride baby that's right that's
you you ride
that's what i'm saying dude i'm
gryffindor dawg everybody going on about
their life right there
too busy for old ghastless boy like me
son
yeah dude it's amazing how many people
don't care when you don't have gas bro
damn heartless bro so then does triple a
come out and pump that gas in there for
you here's the crazy part i've run out
of gas in that exact
same spot damn before one year ago
almost to the day see you would have
known that anniversary
what would one say
yeah i think he'd be able to call the
next time you'll be in that spot
see that's what i need to have him on
speed dog one of the issues with gas is
dude you know the the stations for gas
some of them are six seven miles apart
eight miles apart
some are closed now too huh some are
shut down oh it's it's
people think it's so easy to get gas get
gas you know you get gas you fox
you ever have to siphon some gas out of
another car also known as stealing guys
yeah when i was young people would do
that you know suck that hose
huffing gas bruh yep y'all would do that
we got on mushrooms one time on
halloween and this kid todd drank a
bunch of [ __ ] gas dude did todd died
i honestly dude i don't know if he died
then but he did i i don't think todd's
alive
let's ask the psychic yeah i feel like
nick's past can be pretty dicey with the
psychic
you can already see that nick's worried
i'm trying to be an open book but
there's some there's some stories nick
looks
pretty stressed i don't think that'd be
very fun
nick's like hope hopefully none of us
have ever googled his name and then went
to the third page on google
that's what he's hoping i'm sure when
you
google my name it i am soliciting
for sex workers when we had the sex
worker on
uh you doing what nick blaming it on the
show is that yeah
your sketchy pass when you're trying to
get some ass
no it said i like tweeted like swap
l.a what oh no no maybe it was
who's that young twink though that was
stealing your name
yeah apparently there's a picture of a
young man there
you have way bigger issues
i can't find it uh thank god uh it's not
coming up anymore but yeah so we were
trying to find a sex worker
great episode of this past weekend yeah
i'm not buying this door
and uh so i i was tweeting at sex
workers
um it's called swap yeah sure sweat sex
work is a real work brandon
we'll see what the network is real world
let's see what the psychic says
we'll leave it up to the sidekick but
yeah oh
someone from hell's angel called in or
what and what about i want to know a
little bit more about mon before we just
oh the psychic yeah brendan what do you
want to know huh just whatever else you
can tell us everybody interrupted you
did so he talked to you and
the whole family and just you yeah
brendan she's gonna tell us
you talked to my mom he talked to my
sister
and he talked to a couple of my
relatives over in vietnam as well
you guys kept them busy oh yeah
apparently these things will go on for
hours and what does he say
what is when you guys are talking does
he speak vietnamese does he speak
english no
he speaks in tongues and then he has a
translator there who understands what
he's saying
and then she will translate vietnamese
for us okay and then my mom will
translate from vietnamese to english for
me oh my gosh
[Music]
it's like telling language yeah so by
the time it gets to you then like you're
fine
yeah i'm probably gonna die and i don't
know is it expensive uh
apparently he does it for free the
spirits won't let him have
any worldly possessions other than what
he needs to survive
the lord's work
vietnamese psychics don't make money
like that he needs to come to l.a
because our boy thomas is a
it's a dollar a minute a dollar yeah
well you want to talk about that little
freaking
makeup twink that was running around
that almost that pretty much killed alan
thicke if you wanted
to kill them yeah dude that guy
obviously
is doing it for the cash you know that
little freaking
he had the kardashians on then when they
started bringing up o.j they're like uh
we're gonna edit it here
oh really yeah they won't let them do
any conversation about oj
it sounds like that nightcrawler movie
where jake gyllenhaal purposely killed
someone so he could be on scene to catch
the footage like he killed alan thicke
to prove that he's a real psychic
that's fair
but thomas nick thomas thomas dale would
beat that kid's butt
thomas dale will whoop that kid's butt
only one way actual fight
only one way to find the right
thomasville's strong he's always
sweating even if he's not doing
athletics
you know who would [ __ ] up both of them
is the long island medium with her long
ass nails son
who's the long cleo now cleo passed away
didn't see that question
passed away yeah and she in jail no i'm
talking about long island me and look at
that
jersey's finest dude look at that yeah
she'll put him in that hair she's that
real deal she put him in that freaking
hairspray
wait really miss cleo died pretty sure
call me now for your free reading
call me now for your free reading she'll
put him in that tit clinch dude this
lady
teresa caputo she's not cheap either man
i'm on it right now i'm on luma you're
on lumens
look man i'm on it they got the charcoal
scrub they got the freaking
they got that male moisturizer it's
quality it keeps you classy
you leave the house i even i left the
house and my neighbor's cat looked at me
twice skin does look
real fresh right now dog because i'm
cheat up baby all their products are
formulated specifically for the bros man
made to target skin issues with maximum
efficiency
using top-notch ingredients like
charcoal green tea
extract vitamin c it's not about looking
good it's about feeling good you need
healthy skin man
i know i do quit yelling at me when i'm
moving makes it so
dang easy find the right skin management
system for
you yeah the old days of hey you know
you you get out there to idaho you get
out there to
you know somewhere else it's dry in
denver oh somebody cliffside they hate
you know their wind burn you looking
like a mummy bro oh
sparky has wind burn you know you guys
deserve to look and feel your best and
here's where you start
going boomin skin dot com slash k-a-t-s
that's
s l-u-m-i-n-s-k i n dot com slash
k a t s to get a one month free trial
of everything you need to start your
skin care journey
at home that's lumenskin.com
kats to get your first month free
lumenskin.com
cats yes hello fresh offers so many
recipes to choose from each week dude
each week you're eating the same thing
all the time not anymore don't you mix
it up man there's something for everyone
low calorie
vegetarian family friendly what i like
is man they got the thing you get the
bird sometimes they got a burger option
some of them they got a pork chop option
they got a chicken off mouth is water
and they hit you with a different option
and you can choose they got it printed
out right there you see it's easy
takes about 30 minutes somewhere 20
minutes bro it's never
it's never been easier to make a quality
healthy comfortable meal for you
or a loved one do it with your son get
your son in the kitchen and do it with
him family
do it with a child yeah dog do it with a
kid man
it's flexible it fits your lifestyle
easily change your delivery days or food
preferences
skip a week whenever you need going on
vacation don't worry about it calm down
it's fresh it's delicious food
it's hello fresh and it's they've taken
extra steps to keep their employees and
customers safe
america's number one meal kit son
yep now i got to tell you right now give
them the offer
that you can change your delivery days
or food preferences easy you can skip a
week whenever you need it's
it's flexible you want to go vegetarian
one week we got you
feeding the whole family has never been
easier with larger box sizes
for more servings and more savings give
me offer dog give them the freaking
offer i'm going to tell you right now go
to hellofresh.com80kats
that's right and use code 80 cats to get
a total
of 80 buckaroonies off including free
shipping on your first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
again that's hellofresh.com
the number eight the number zero k a t s
and use code
eight zero cats to get a total of eighty
dollars off including free shipping
on your first box
hello we got to get some dang mediums on
brendan do you have any
uh my mom blues in it but my mom does
too well what's funny cat is that when
you said it my mom had me
talk to a man named fernando or
something over in uh
outside of scottsdale by yourself by
yourself yeah yeah
it's about 30 minutes sure and he said
something happened when i was 22 or 23
years old and i've never been the same
that's what he said i don't know and i
wrote down to think about what happened
and then i forgot about it but
um wow yeah it cost like 40 and
i did feel pretty good after it though
because apparently what he does is he
goes through
and um that's him that could be him
this [ __ ] psycho brendan what do you
mean he has a website
yeah right that's a good point would you
believe the freaking
the other little guy that looks like
rachel maddow
the only one i believe in any of this is
cat's 14 over the shirt off
i thought you hated him a minute ago
nope i believe him now
well i believe thomas too i gotta i
gotta see for myself my mom leaves in
the the tarot card readings
i grew up here doing tarot card readings
realization like first day of school is
gonna be
tough then and you're denouncing all
these seances
yeah and your mother yeah raise she
going freaking tarot card reading some
man holding a pot of gold under a son
oh my god dude dude so you went and you
enjoyed that and he said at 23 you're
probably molested
he said that away the haircut huh
he said something happened and i and i i
even asked him if i was molested
and he said he didn't think that i was
but if you get molested
he said only you would know my man
but he said if you get molested at 23
that's when we had a big dis so 10
minutes of what was us discussion
arguing really not or just discussing
how you keep getting
molested if you're of age you know yeah
kind of like a lot of crystalline
accusers you know yeah or terry crews
yeah yeah
what happened oh yeah some dude grabbed
his dingle he said he was at a party and
agent grabbed his dick
and he went on this whole tour and how
he's molested some agent grabbed me i
wrote a book about
somebody did it you're lying somebody
grabbed my leg one time or it could have
been my dick but i think it was my leg
dude terry crews bro here's the thing
it's a big dude to grab him
yeah yeah he was like i wanted to beat
his ass but then i figured i'd never
work in hollywood again
terry crews i don't like that that's
fair dude terry crews is a modern day
mlk man he does his own thing bro he
literally does he has some good points
he's staying
a good yeah it's so easy to just go with
the flow man
i like to it's easy people just pick a
side and it's like that's
if you're not on this side and then it's
like yeah i actually like takers i was
making jokes there but i actually
like people are a lot more because you
beat your ass i'd beat the [ __ ] out of
terry
people are a lot more uh i don't give a
original than that
even look i mean chappelle's kind of
like a he he does his own thing
people might say oh he's a blankie or
whatever you know
a belonging
against my friend jebel over here dude
i was in a club growing up what should i
ever heard
really i was in a club growing up called
wiggers and blankies
[Laughter]
shout out devin deeku he went to jail
for murder shout out him
that makes sense shout outs
he was kind of a blankie a little bit oh
okay actually i don't think he was dude
i think just i was i think i was both
actually king or stinger blankies or
wiggers man
i mean i king of man because it's great
i king him too they're fun dude paul
wall santino
who else chin almost blanky eminem
what's what's up what's up asian who
acts black yes because i know some
asians get a little too loosey-goosey
with the n-word
oh yeah there's an exact skin there's a
asian and mike perry
there's an asian gang he's one percent
black to his defense he did uh
ancestry.com and he said he was one
percent black well first of all also
i'm not going to tell mike perry he
can't use any word that's okay
i'm not i'd love to see the person that
wants to go up to him and discuss it
there's a few who will yeah but his
name's darren tale
[Laughter]
oh that'd be a good fight those two guys
huh not for darren till
he's too ranked high like yeah yeah my
parents nothing to lose
well mike perry's right now i think he's
in rehab because he [ __ ] up that old
dude in a restaurant
can't have it you can't have it oh your
boy dc lost this weekend new orleans
finest
lots
second finest let's be honest who's the
finest the diamond
the diamond dustin poury actually man
both these guys are great and there he
is right there he's gonna be a father
man i know
i think it's gonna make him i think it's
going to be a good thing i mean look
we're all just
judging him i'm not he's always have you
met him
i have not met him but i like him i
think he's going through tough times i
think him having a
kid's going to get him on the straight
path because he has skills i'm excited
for him and i've always thought he's a
real dude
you know uh i think he reads social
media too much and it [ __ ] with him is
he a blood
nope oh he's flouridian no
he's floridian man what is that what
were you sad your boy
because it's no i was locked out man it
was look man i just think he's just such
a class act i mean
you did it with one eye so yeah and
obviously you know like
yeah he's uh you've been poked in the
eye he's a national treasure
really minds are i barely have any eye
like most people poke guys like this
yours we gotta go like this
right really your fault they're far
apart
my eyes are lean and also one of them's
a little kind of sideways i got that paw
wall bruh oh okay see you got big guys
dog
and they're and they're far apart they
used to call me china when i was young
because they're far apart no but uh i
think because they were thin and yeah
because i looked chinese a little bit
wow
no offense to anybody chinese no they
did not do that
a lot of people did no they didn't yeah
yeah you got that sniper right
they won't do it to his face though no
they won't say that to his face
look man what the best i mean the
amazing thing about his is just no
excuses after the fight he just always
takes response
just full responsibility you know just
admirable
it's almost like you want to be whether
you win or lose that's how you want to
be that's what i feel like after
watching and listening to him but man
that was a battle man
those guys back out yep
yeah and it's how we credited uh how he
credited stipe with just like the
adjustments that he made and trying
something different and
man i wanted to see him win but it's
it's funny some guys i feel like win or
lose they win
oh he's gonna be fine either way he's a
whole first ballot hall of famer either
way
yeah he's already a champion then your
boy sugar shawn
oh man i know [ __ ] his foot up but
then cheeto vera
yeah that's my guy you gotta give him
credit man yeah he won
you know he won it's exciting for him i
think it's exciting for their whole
division
because they're still they're all
they're around that 10 to 15 range and
rankings in their division yeah they'll
be fine yeah but i just think it's
exciting for the whole division because
the top is pretty stacked they got that
peter yan up there federeon
yeah superstar and then you got al
jermaine sterling in the same division
right cody santa hagan marlon marias
dude so it's crazy yeah so there's you
watching that
oh man i ran out of gas dude this so
this would happen
[Laughter]
and shout out to to colin bro who works
here and who also apparently is the
freaking petrol plug
man because you call him when you're out
of gas well he and i were supposed to
meet up here
last night oh sunday night last night i
was coming here last night
and i my car didn't have any more gas in
it and i said damn
i'm out of gas and then he had to pick
you up
and some people think here's what the
one thing i will give credit to myself
some people are like oh i don't know
i think the trans men i might have a
flat tire you always see some dumb girl
out there looking at all their tires
yeah like oh one of my tires is out of
gas i think
i heard a girl say that one time no
offense girls but also
offense yeah dude last time i ran out of
dude
and i was telling a story brendan oh
sorry
and i was out of gas dude i knew
immediately so there's no bs and for me
i don't have to look under the hood and
be like oh damn you know
i need to call my stepdad yeah no i know
what's up i was out of gas
but here's what happened i was supposed
to watch the fights over uh
i was going over to david spades i met
up with him and dana carvey actually
which was pretty crazy to have some
dinner
so i get there and then the valet comes
back and says hey sir your car won't
start
so my car won't start over there and
it's uh and i said oh it's out of gas
and they got us looked at me and i was
like
did david spade see all this oh yeah i
was like do you you guys have any gas i
figured there's a lot of guys there
somebody's got a little bit of gas on
them yeah you know
so he's like we don't have any gas here
and so i go
out there and this noble or some [ __ ]
that's noble yeah
right yeah and so the standard so i have
to go so spade actually gives me a ride
to a couple gas stations to pick up a
gallon and get gas because you can't put
gas
this is a first and look i'm first
ballot run out of gasser
because i know that you can't get a milk
jug and fill it with gas
it has to be a the standard red yeah
because it will eat splashes around
wouldn't it oh yeah i got two right now
in my thing yeah but it will eat the
it will eat right through a milk jug so
if you try to put gas in the milk jug
eat right through it
so don't try that's a cheap way out
because it's 22 for that red can
it's a dollar fifty for that gallon of
water empty it out and then spill gas
all over yep
so anyway i got the gallon of gas i go
back to my car i didn't realize in the
little spigot of the jug they put a
stopper in there you gotta take it out
so i put the thing into my gas tank all
the gas kind of goes into the thing but
then runs along
it comes out hot mess then the valet man
comes over and he says
uh brother brother in my country i'm a
famous mechanic in my country
um lie seemed like a lot of famous
mechanics
unless you were getting some drag unless
your [ __ ]
vincent van gear shift you know yeah
there's nobody behind this
yeah famous
let him have that all right he's a
valentine and i did let him have it yeah
i showed a lot of respect man i respect
anybody that's hard working this guy's a
hard-working guy
yeah liar but yes and he's like you have
bigger problem bigger problem you know
you have splash bad splash you know and
i'm telling them look it's just the can
so anyway i had to go take an uber
and at this point gas is pooled all in
front of the gas the gallon i did have
pooled out in front there's people
waiting to go sit down it's like a nice
restaurant so
everybody's pissed one old guy keeps
trying to smoke and they keep stopping
him and i think he doesn't understand
why
so he's all pissed you know so anyway
fast forward finally bro is about an
hour and a half ordeal i went and got
two more gallons of gas got back there
i had gas all up and down my arms the
entire scent though
i don't mind this smell i don't mind it
i just get nervous because i forgot to
shower and then i went to sleep and i
got nervous i woke up and had a scary
dream but it's fair
um anyway man yeah i ran out of gas one
time around to guess one time well
more than one but the one one i remember
i just not
i just knocked out biggest win in my
career i knocked out merkel crow cop i'm
in denver right so i'm on cloud nine
and i bought a [ __ ] hummer h2 a big
ass hunter like arnold schwarzenegger
and the most brendon thing you could do
yeah in denver they're dope so i'm
driving that big thing
and i see it's low on gas i'm like i can
push it runs out of gas
so i have to put in it's in the middle
of the [ __ ] intersection right around
oh so i'm
trying to push this [ __ ] hummer to
the gas station i get the gas station
yo man do you have one of those things
and he's like what happened i'm like
right out of gas and he's like yeah we
got one that goes
it was literally the weekend before i
beat crocodiles
aren't you the ufc fighter or yes did
you just be [ __ ] merkel croke up i go
yeah around the gas he goes
damn that's sad
he's just saying he's sad man he's right
we used to do gas
and goes all the time but then the
conicals got smart because remember you
you
they didn't have the card you had to go
inside so you could pump gas then pay
so my mom was like i'm low on gas can
you guys get me gasps i mean my brother
just
pull up i would pump fill it up we drive
off that was a thing
oh stealing gas pump and jump they call
it wow
yeah i remember a cop came one time i
was at my friend's house taking a nap
and um a cop came and knocked on the
door and
accused me of stealing gas and i had
been pumped
pump and go so i had to drive back there
and pay for it that's what pissed me off
really and it was only like three
dollars too that's embarrassing
sometimes mom buy can you fill up the
gas and give me four dollars
here's a guy who's probably gonna get
accused of a hate crime at some point
this is mark coming at you from that
work truck
i got a name game for you sandwiches
the name of the game is salmon's baby
i'm talking hot
sandwiches old sandwiches oh yeah boom
temperature sandwich oh yeah ice cream
sandwich will do any meat between
two pieces of bread that's what i call a
sammy baby
so hit it up heavy with them sandwiches
what's going on it's like thompson girl
in a different light
down with the thickness pop us down 20
pounds get some
gang gang buzz buzz yeah
bro i can't believe that guy took the
panty off his head and quit sending it
and got a new job
and r.i.p to that guy he passed away
we've been trying to get in touch with
him for months haven't we
now he's driving long haul but i'll
respect that man look brother thank you
for being out there there's nothing
braver than driving along
all you out there 14 gears bro not
knowing which
one is 14 gear you're going up mountains
and steep mountains and [ __ ] because
they had crossed off you were nine
and you went 11 running you in two dude
that's right my grandpa my uncle's
that's a lifelong truck driver so nice
to go with him yeah that's that arm math
baby you got to do it right
eating [ __ ] food all the time all
those stop those coming goes
yeah lot lizards knocked on your door
they get to sleep there right
yeah there's a uh have you seen the
documentary a lot of the documentary
no have you not seen that what
it's about lot lizards yeah what on hbo
dark or some [ __ ] yeah you don't even
research your own life dude
yeah it's on the netflix whoa
here's somebody right here i thought i
made up the term lot lizard i'm a tomboy
at heart oh he's having a trailer for a
lot lizards oh my god
i think it helps me to make more money
helps me more look look more girly
this is on the she looks like otis nixon
a little bit you can play for the braves
i will say when i'm doing
my hustle
and dealing with truck drivers it is
what it is
well yeah man it's a tough racket
it is i think why because the truck
driver has been driving forward
the first time oh yeah they've been
having a tough time yeah this is what
kind of person i am because i've never
been on my own
that's the truck driver there i can't
call that [ __ ] no no no that's
her husband
that is not me apparently she lost her
ass too
is it brendan sorry
that's her husband people put too much
emphasis
on things that you can see
half of what you see isn't really what
you're saying it's
i don't know what you're talking about
someone there's a lot lizards
does she do palm readings too or what's
going on here
the fact that brendan thought he made up
lot liz it absolutely blows my mind
i like it man i i yeah we should have
never told you
i mean that trailer looks [ __ ]
terrible but the trailer is not a good
trailer
no that was awful yeah you could get
something much better producer over at
draft
drastic graphics with martial she was
like what you see
isn't really what you get with lights
yeah man is she a motivational speaker
she's a notivational speaker speakers so
this guy's talking about sandwiches he
wants to have a contest doesn't he nick
yeah name game oh i name the sandwiches
okay oh [ __ ] hey what's up
damn take it easy
[Laughter]
nixon a lot god bless
sandwiches period like cold cuts or any
sandwiches
hot sandwiches cold sandwiches hot
coffee cool coffee
donuts hot coffee cool coffee go ahead
you little
lizard i call cold coffee i don't know
what they call it polar bear coffee
go ahead lot lizard um i'm gonna start
off in honor
of our boy mumbling munn the
medium i'm going to drop this freaking
yum puff on you
the bond me yeah there you go
shout out dude jesus christ or you call
it
the bond mine i'm sure when you see it
i don't know what you're talking about
let's go with that peanut butter and
jelly hitter my favorite
oh extra on the butter you feel me that
basic [ __ ]
thought nugget there's nothing more
american than a peanut butter
jelly sandwich you [ __ ] delinquent
not surprised you chose that dude
what's yours um i'm gonna go with a
sandwich
that a lot of people enjoy
i'm gonna go with something that i would
something seem like it's probably a
delicacy to nick
the grilled cheese
my grandma would put him at george
foreman grills those are amazing oh yeah
dude i will say this dude my mom used to
grill uh peanut butter and jellies and
those were
good bro you ever had that nick oh yeah
i'm the george foreman
oh wow oh yeah everything went on the
george foreign must have been rich
dude i'll tell you what i used to do on
the former two a little thing about my
hawaiian friends while i'm talking about
that
spam sandwich dog little mustard spam
what's up cat it's good that's your
medium about that [ __ ]
okay dude what's up all right bro i've
had enough of this [ __ ] conversation
dude
because i'm gonna go with that
muffalatta baby
bring it up nick what is that bring up
that freaking dirty muffalata bro
that hard bro no you're talking about
that hard hit you keep making
pseudonic sandwiches doug yeah because i
was like i've never heard of god damn
you rich son well no y'all need to quit
eating inside of gas stations and
[ __ ] live a little
i'll tell you my favorite sandwich is
that roast beef hit or
dug with a nice sharp cheddar a roast
beef sandwich that sharp cheddar don't
even start naming
cheeses again i already won that one i
won that one i lost on pies though yeah
bro
you lost on a lot dude bro i'm not even
playing games with y'all's fake ass bruh
one thing i'll say right now is dude i'm
gonna go with that
fried oyster poor boy dog straight out
of louisiana bring up that picture
nicholas
boom mfer put that in your fat cheeks
bruh
put that in your fat bike riding ass
bruh you know what i'm saying get out of
there
dude i'll ride a couple miles for that
that
nice ass lobster roll saying bring up
that [ __ ] lobster roll
oh he's going off shore yeah dog i'm
taking to them spiders of the sea
dude hugs as they call it he's going off
shore
baby favorite and dude they got cousins
maine lobster sandwiches here it's a
food truck
bro bro twenty four dollars a pop is
that how much it is twenty four dollars
a pop
food truck i'll say this bro i i thought
they were impressive
until i saw them in another city and
that's when i realized
are they in maine though it would no it
wasn't maine same truck same
place yeah dude worldwide mr worldwide
nah
oh that's out here oh is it ever it's my
favorite food truck all the food trucks
that's numero
[ __ ] i like authentic bruh 24 bucks
so first
for i'm allergic to shellfish i can't
eat this you can't have self shellfish
no
nothing no bugs megan makes the best
lobster rolls yeah
rather than homemade these things your
friend megan these things
ain't nobody believe in that these
things look nasty bro yeah
lobster rolls never
the answer's never bro you're the one
who eats them out of a
truck yeah dog that's a legit truck
they're not your friend
megan you're the one who come out of a
truck like some damn [ __ ]
lot lizard dude
i love them man okay my sandwich sure
all right i'll go with uh let me think
of a good sandwich for you right
now any sandwich we're gonna be here all
[ __ ] day no we won't bro i know you
foster that's one of his defense tactics
dude that's a brand new
i think the lobster off he goes with the
oyster thing
i'm saying you were going to say it
again but but they get limited though we
can't do another lobster sandwich man no
you can't you know
so is that the rule you can't use
another meat twice bro if you want to
bust a nut in a theater nothing helps by
having a little bit of that
peter paul rubin in your mouth
i don't like rubens huh i don't like
rubens oh god
you like rubens yes son nah
that one looks nice oh that one looks
that one looks nice the first one you
see
actually enough cheese on it yeah
actually that looks really good you
don't like reuben's pick a sammy
well nothing makes my day better than
watching theo deep throw a six
incher of meatball subs
what's up bro take it to the dome that
meatball
sub oh i love a nice meatball they are
good who thought of that what a great
idea
he's getting flashbacks of jared's
sister
take two inches off of that sub
okay how many things i 500 foot long
[Laughter]
uh yeah i was humming that four inch
round around dude
my penis is shaped like a candy corn
do we call it a draw yeah we'll be here
all day
you can't have a whole episode of just
sandwiches yeah just my fat ass name in
sandwich is all bro you know how many
fat guys are right now listening to this
loving us foaming out the mouth
yeah you know how many guys that
couldn't get tickets to burke chrysler's
drive-in tour right now
are absolutely using this as their
second option dude let's get cats medium
on here and get your friend megan in
here to make these lobster roll stuff
she makes good lobster rolls brandon i'm
not buying it dude
but you'll buy it out of a truck [ __ ]
yeah oh
[ __ ] you got a debate club this this
young man went to a trump rally or what
kingdom esteem what up my name is hunter
and yes i realize i look extremely
swollen wisdom teeth
and this has to do with part of my
debate club
so the reason i'm so swollen and look
like a freaking
bloated italian who just drowned and
came back to life
thick boy bike club it's because i just
had all four of my wisdom teeth removed
and honestly i'm still a little high
from the meds so i thought it'd be a
good idea to send in a video
but yeah getting your wisdom teeth
removed do you get all four
out or do you do what some people have
done that ancient neanderthal maybe that
primal
that primal man and do you leave all
four of these suckers in
what's it gonna be yeah in all
seriousness though
you guys have uh honestly inspired me a
lot i love the fighter
and the kid and i love uh this past
weekend uh from both you guys it truly
motivated me a lot and i hope to one day
make a difference in this world
and honestly become a guest on you guys
podcast so um
yeah gang gang buzz buzz wisdom teeth
removal
well we got a chair open on firing the
kids huh
soon dude bro you could easily call it
the fighter in the cavities right now
in a hot beat army
rope obviously this dude lost the final
bout in karate kid
i'm gonna go out and say that yeah he
does
no man look it's very kind to you bro
yeah shout out to you man
there's a stream like stingray i'm
saying something nice to this guy
oh sorry man thank you very much for the
nice message
and also brendan this guy really looks
like it could be your son
from the future sending you a video you
might be right
did you even think about that you might
be right so
uh thank you bro for the support of the
podcast it's really tough when all of
our friends are sex offenders
to stay in business um
it's exhausting it's exhausting yeah
accused sex offenders and that's really
what i'm moving
just joking um i mean we got more proof
on guys in this room than any either two
of those dudes
are you looking at me dude huh okay
we'll see what that medium says jen
yeah jim nick real stressed about it you
know we couldn't find them dude they're
pretty busy
oh yeah so i don't believe that [ __ ]
anyway man that'd be a bad episode
nick subtly slips into this episode that
he has sexual allegations on this
dude if you google me saving me bro it's
like some guy
looking for lot lizards and [ __ ]
silences of the way you got to get out
in front of it
that's true that came to his defense
real bad oh it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you google it
no it's real you guys know this um
google has a liberal agenda i love how
also nick pulls up the wrong guy from
karate kid as well
i haven't seen it you haven't seen
karate kid
i saw the one with jaden smith oh
that was disappointing
i think i saw it once but the the new
series on youtube bread is killing it no
again do you know what i'm talking about
don't you macchio
thank you oh the karate kid he won you
said the guy who lost at the end of
karate kid
no he said he would say if he lost if he
lost
original karate kid and i don't even
know what i said nick so i'm sorry
it's daniel's son i'm just i'm [ __ ]
around i guess twice in one week and i'm
40.
so i'm not doing that good but um damn
he also looks like my son you know
and yeah daniel's son your son
tiger son wow i'm going to say right now
um this guy's question was
wisdom teeth all four at the time who
has wisdom teeth in here
i still have mine me too like the
[ __ ] lord intended bro
you still have them [ __ ] dude it's got
hard hearing you say that first of all
um i can't believe you still have your
wisdom to eat
hell yeah dude i'm just joking is that
like a young person thing
i don't know if i have mine or not you
do not have yours i have mine in no
way and that's why my teeth that's why
my my bottom teeth look like city
skyline because it's pushing them in
well i got mine like that cincinnati
chili huh yeah doug
that [ __ ] well so who has nick
nah you got yours removed no i still
have mine [ __ ] yeah
you're a man now in asian cultures is it
popular to get your wisdom teeth out it
seems like that seems like a very
american thing no it is because it makes
your face more v-line
that's why that's why that sounds like a
rich asian thing
i know the girls that have gotten their
wisdom teeth removed their vietnamese my
friends
their face changed so they all want to
get it removed say no more
isn't that show thirsty
what is that thirsty rotations is that
what it's called i think so it's called
crazy rotations my bad thirsty rich
asian sounds way better
that sounds like a porn i would watch
that yeah
i'm not watching any more porn again
good for you um
relapse again huh you had a relapse i
mean i just can't handle it
i just can't handle it keep them 32 68
bunch of [ __ ] god gave them to us for
a reason man i left my [ __ ] in
you're riding those rock sockets dude i
had to get them out because i was
getting infected
yeah so like i had to they were like you
gotta get another thing trying to take
down the black man that's what i said i
was like these white
teeth corona
these white bro it hurt it hurts to hear
it dude i'll take whatever
whatever it takes to get this face
scanner here i'm sick of having these
junk
chunky monkey face nothing the teeth
isn't going to help dude
that's what you just said it'll make
your face look like something tell us
more about this i don't know why anybody
interrupted you
i wish i could take mine out because my
face could be a little thinner
wow that's head though chin my head's
big but i mean it does make a difference
when it goes from
like a v line but what do you what do
you think when you hear that kat when
you hear somebody say that
i'm so sad there's nothing wrong with
your face or your face
i've been put to sleep a lot by men
maybe that's what happened when you were
23.
it's your wisdom teeth there it is
against my will
yeah maybe you want me to keep it play
with dang dang i have to ask my mom
mm-hmm wait nick you have yours i do
damn everybody has them oh i'm the only
one that's got them out no theos is out
i will i'm missing i think too how many
do you have
four only four well it depends how big
your mouth is if you're
if your mouth can support that's your
teeth you can leave them uh
that sounds like something that yeah
that's what they say really yours are
out cat
next time you have like a strong chin so
is your mom
i don't know if that's a good thing
that's a great i know that's a good
thing that's a good thing brendan
shouldn't have said that i should have
that's a good thing
it's an attractive thing yeah thank you
yeah cat i think your face looks very
well
structured and nice as i do think
everybody's facing here almost everyone
and i think that uh that
i it makes me sad also chin that you
want to get your teeth taken out to look
different
to look like a young woman i wanted to
do it before but now
i'm more accepting of my face well i
still want to do it
you do brendan what are you gonna do
with it i don't know i just found out
this information makes your face skinny
it contours it yeah
dude don't you see though look at the
hill you guys are going down first you
know
your buddy gets his eyes you know sucked
off or whatever
oh you're trying to get his lips done
yeah that was a bad idea
but then where does it start it starts
with the teeth and then you get the
[ __ ] elbows rounded it never ends
yeah
you know then you're [ __ ] you know
then maybe we can get three for one does
it hurt you
do your teeth hurt you not at all you're
literally just doing it to
have a skin in your face your belly and
then brennan you you get meds afterwards
too
and i love men i threw mine away
you're mad yeah i ain't taking it how
long did you throw them away
this was years ago were they white pills
too yeah they were white oh yeah
yeah i was like these white pills going
down the toilet
years ago years ago hurts my heart like
27. do you if you would tell me you did
a week ago
you'd see him at your house this week
video of it on my own
he's definitely been he seemed like he's
been jay's got his taken out his face
still pretty fat
i don't know if this is true i'll show
you through all this pain
i'll show you a girl a picture of a girl
who had it before i mean had her teeth
in and took it out and see how her face
changes
your friend's full of [ __ ] she had no
teeth taken out but then she also got
that kylie jenner
no no yeah it makes me sad
when i hear that jen because i think
yeah to getting that to adjust your face
but
also if it makes you happy dude yeah
[ __ ] what i think and you're supposed to
take him out anyways right
no i don't know where that nerve got
started if you have to take them out
if they rotten yeah so a lot of people
they get infections like chappelle yeah
yeah i was gonna it was like getting
infected it helps me grind the food
better
it's just money dentists just want more
money that's what they say you know
dentists number one job commits suicide
why because they're not [ __ ] teeth
all day probably because they've been
pulling teeth out of people's mouths
that don't need them pulled out and if i
did that for five years i'd take my own
life they wanted to be doctors
but they're staring at teeth yeah but
every now and then they'll sneak around
and pull something out of your leg or
out of your [ __ ] hip
yeah play with your ding dong while
you're under medicine oh you got a
[ __ ]
you got a molar in under your dick yeah
they'll sneak they'd be like oh you got
a [ __ ] incisor and you do it was like
right after him every wednesday and get
put to sleep they were like damn you got
to overbite in your ass
we found a cavity in your dick hole
yeah you're like that is a cavity yeah
that is a county dog
so what are you doing in there yeah
and why yeah why are we behind the
movies over biting your ass
what's this all right here's the young
guy here's lee bryce has another
question right here
i will close it out with one king of
their stinging
up guys uh david coming at you from
tuscaloosa alabama
little roll tide action it's out of king
of the stinger for you guys
custom jerseys king it or sting it
i got that brett shaw hitter oh
authentic cu buffalo jersey wow that's
wild man that's dope
i'm i'm a big fan of the custom jerseys
oh yes you are yeah
yes you are um that's awesome man that's
crazy do you have one of those at home
uh my dad and my brother have the game
worn ones they're framed
i don't have one myself did those have
your last name on it yeah yeah
wow damn how much you think it's worth
now
not much not much i'd go this bro
two bond b's okay
jersey come on now yeah i'd be honored
to have one i think it's awesome i'm
rocking i'll tell you right now
i'm just giving you a hard time because
i'm just at the university of colorado
selling them [ __ ] i need to see a
goddamn percentage i'll tell you that
right now
okay how many yards did you have when
you were there uh i don't know
i mean i had some few catches but you
did yeah damn
you're pretty quick though did you get
in the end zone or not
no never scored touchdown [ __ ] dude
that's crazy
i blocked the punt that was a touchdown
you did yeah against kansas why didn't
the coach give you more carries man
because i'm white
who was y'all's darker running back uh
um
lawrence vickers and he went on to play
pretty funny yeah
yeah he was he was a captain for the
cowboys and uh
for uh the cowboys in the cleveland
browns he's the captain of the team
wow it's a pretty cool guy huh yeah
great guy wow
2005 that three receptions eight yards
y'all want a bowl right i love that dude
uh yeah we want a bunch of balls dude if
you haven't seen
the colorado play they play every week
against colorado state and the score is
57-56 and we beat the [ __ ] out of them
every year bro every
every year i will look at television one
night and it will be
ninth overtime and it's colorado versus
colorado state bro and they are
brilliant we never lost them we beat
them every year
y'all really every year [ __ ] them dude
yeah colorado's state of what
well there's the program just got
canceled for being racist did it really
yeah f that they canceled the program
yeah like you know
a lot of people canceled uh corona
college state was like
we got a problem because their coach was
saying some racist [ __ ] i guess
yeah damn they say racist things in
colorado not at university of colorado
colorado state does the rams damn
that guy yeah that guy looks like a
dropping bomb
i don't know man looks like sergeant
slaughter
yeah he looks really intense
yeah so they're gonna sit this year out
he looks like squints mcmahon doesn't he
a little bit
it looks like uh
remember sergeant slaughter all right he
does look like sergeant slaughter who
said that
nick dude nick finally got one
reference fast dude it starts now
through the end of the year you in
i'm in well let's don't make it whole
let's make it let's make it through this
september okay
or let's do the year because we need
time to do it
[Laughter]
damn a little bit that's it how about
that thing i posted last night cat this
dude
james co gave me my first job in uh
tv in hollywood i was doing oh i saw
that 10 30 i know i can't believe you
posted oh
yeah the 10 30 slot at a local la
station
nobody was watching sports yeah baby
show up cheeto vera hitting you up
marlin on the frickin
ones yeah i gave him when i start he's
ecuadorian isn't he
cheeto yeah yeah wow james coe he's
korean right
ko ko is a korean name yeah i didn't
know he's an asian yeah he's eight so
he's probably half then right he's asian
he's a big deal i think he's won
three what what emmy's a ship for uh his
podcasting yeah i remember we should go
and was only about three people
that was sad 10 30 at night nobody
watched what you were doing you got to
start somewhere
yeah starting from the bottom now you're
here yeah you didn't pay me either
they didn't pay me they did it oh well
just trying to get them rep son there
you go look at that 10 30 fox 11 and
that was on espn
[ __ ] no local la news station
james co right there give me my start
said why don't you come i'll
talk some sports i brought a suit and co
is he japanese no he's korean korean it
should be korean yeah
wow four-time emmy winner there you go
he was great man all right james d
ko a follow k-o-h yeah there he is
and um what else do we have here i just
want to make
sure everybody said anything they want
to say
oh we got some really good chad right my
rides that we didn't get to this week
so keep sending those in clown my hounds
some relationship advice
uh we got a really fun patreon episode
coming up next month it's going to be
submissions from all cats crew family
members
cat's sister my sister some
some shops some vons some lacy's yeah
damn i'm gonna get my dad that'd be dope
i don't know do you reach out to some
people in my family i don't want to know
who's doing it
yeah because i don't want to start
getting any fights or anything
yeah don't don't ask my dad to do it and
don't bring up corona king or saint
corona cause he'll go on a ramp
jay was the one helping reach out to the
shops i think he was gonna ask your dad
but that's fine
bring it on dad we can do it on here bro
i don't know
yeah i don't care who does it from my
family as long as they include some of
their own personality i just don't want
them just showing up flat
yeah yeah i'm gonna talk with them on
the phone and try to hammer something
out that makes
sense okay oh i'll just give you my
dad's number okay
cool cool my mom just lost her job so
she'll be like king you're stinging it
your son paying all your bills
[Laughter]
that sounds like my sister right now
there you go and i want to get your boy
mun on here
see what he's doing and how hard i love
to does he talk to whites as well or
what is this about
i think is it vietnamese that's a good
question i think you need a vietnamese
translator but i think he's fine with
we'll do it once he sees cat i bet god i
know her
oh i know i gotta get an update on my
past lover who won't leave me alone so
we'll probably try to
get him up what is that that's a cat
sister just a preview we won't play our
video now but we got cat sister
she sent in some relationship advice she
doesn't that too
yeah you know what you think there's
somebody hiding under her shirt
that's a tattoo man that's drawing
that's patriot.com king of the steak
damn nick slang i'll pay for it
my only fans account what the [ __ ] jesus
christ
gosh let me know whenever you knew my
sister or my mom
cheese and rice you said well i'm gonna
attempt for their bill
since that guy got you that jersey i'm
gonna get you got that jersey i'm gonna
get you
one of my cheerleading ones the
louisville ones yeah that'd be dope to
have your name on the back
it does not i could write it on there
though yeah write it on i want the real
mccoy
all right and i might get you each one
of you guys one of these neat unique
western hats oh look at that
maybe we could get a lot lizard in the
culture corner like a real authentic lot
less
we had a sex worker on this past weekend
and you can listen to that episode
whenever you want on youtube and
i want a lot and that's why i was
googling it
real loudly uh your honor i don't
remember
asking nick to google her
all right we gotta get out of here man
love you guys
good to see you brother good to see you
too bye
bye brendan
[Music]
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
theo do not the type of dude that got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in a club can you pick me up
king and a sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you